thing they come to give you advice
they've been through situations right
you have pretty much made into the UK
they they left a country where the
amount of people that are living in the
country are like a small minority right
and it's a blessing to actually be able
to leave that country because of the
situation that's going on in that
country so they have all this life
advice these are people that used to
learn in difficult circumstances right
that some of them actually in zinc
culture went to war as well they have
all their life experience they've heard
all these things like guidance pretty
much they want to give for you for your
life but you guys feel like it's control
because you want to be so liberal you
don't want to listen to your parents and
that's why I have a disagreement with
you guys because you want the Western
culture because it gives you that
liberalism that I can just do whatever I
want but you're doing whatever you want
you have no responsibility and you have
no one to account you